with music playing on the patrol car
radio it begins as a routine traffic
stop
within minutes though the driver of this
Mercedes was dead
the policeman pulling him over his
accused murderer Walter Scott had been
stopped for a faulty brake light officer
Michael Slager approaches and questions
him about the car the officer returns to
his car and moments later mr. Scott runs
no one's sure why his family say perhaps
because he was wanted for unpaid child
support in the noise that follows we can
hear a shout of taser we know what
happened next
[Applause]
filmed by a passerby Slager shooting mr.
Scott in the back as he ran away the
officer had claimed he fired because he
feared for his life he's now in custody
and facing a murder charge
two years ago Officer Slager was cleared
of using excessive force against Mario
Givens officials are now reviewing that
decision if they even try to listen to
me and really investigated that man
would have probably gonna laugh cuz he
wouldn't have been an officer in a field
his lawyer says it reflects a systemic
problem in the city but there are plenty
who see one across America as a whole an
incident that started out so routinely
has added to the momentum for change the
question is when if ever that's going to
come Gregg Milam Sky News Washington